[Music]
Nik vial has officially passed the
bachelor torch to re Lyon Dyke a junior
now these two seem similar both looking
for love after heartbreak and long
histories with the franchise both 36
years old but are eight lzt backs or the
similarities end how different or
similar are you in terms of what Nick
was like as a bachelor gorgeous two
completely different people to be honest
watching Nick season I could really tell
who he I mean I don't know if he opened
himself up as much as I did and I feel
like I felt really strongly for more
than one person and it's because I was
just I think really open to the process
and I think that's the biggest
difference between us by all got engaged
- Vanessa Grimaldi on his finale but the
two split after just five months and
some of vials contestants spoke out
about him after the show throughout the
season he just totally changed and I
just feel like you lost that realness
and the voice Bachelet history so what
kind of bachelor is Ari I'm a real
person you know and I feel like I really
know what I want and you want marriage
out of all this yeah exactly
I want to get married and I want to
start a family and you know and that's
important to me so say you're engaged
with starting a family be something you
want to do pretty soon yeah for sure
[Music]